now the Liberal Democrat leadership
contenders have clashed over brexit and
Boris Johnson in the Sky News debate Joe
Swenson and said Davey were united
against going into coalition with the
Jeremy Corbyn led Labor Party and they
described pursuing a No Deal brexit as
irresponsible and disgusting when it
push comes to shove we're actually
trying to define what breaks that
actually means it turns out even the
brexit ears do not agree with one
another so the thought that there is a
majority in this country for a No Deal
breaks it yeah you know that is a
fantasy that does not exist there's not
a majority in this country for a new
deal breaks there and to pursue that
course of action if it's not what the
majority people in the country want and
it will wreck our economy and damage our
security and our public services that is
the height of a responsibility
the difference I would bring is I would
be pretty robust against the people like
Johnson I'm straining at the leash to
get a Johnson because I think he's one
of the most deceitful politician about
politics I think it's likely to win less
less admit it and I I what he needs to
be exposed for the politician the years
he and and Jeremy Hunt actually are
prepared to see millions of people lose
their jobs by pursuing their Tory
ideology over brexit Jeremy Hunt
yesterday said he said he he thought
it'd be okay for business Wentworth
Shelton won't have food on the table
that is disgusting Adam was hosting that
debate he's here to reflect on on how it
went some points have sharp disagreement
Adam but actually the tone of the thing
was very good-natured yes and clear that
they're both going to carry on working
with each other whoever wins this
particular contest of course the
contrast really is Asian experience Joe
Swinson much younger than Edie Davey but
also of course that as far as the three
main parties are concerned she would be
the only woman leader there is Nicola
Sturgeon in Scotland but what was
interesting was both of them had served
as ministers in the coalition government
both of them were saying that they
believed in participation and working
with other parties but not only were
they saying they couldn't work with
Jeremy Corbyn the message was also well
I sorta don't know that they can work
with Boris Johnson the message was also
very strongly that they couldn't work
with Jeremy Corbyn either